by the grace of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idy waiting to hit our Target of
2 million we have fully purchased four
properties in London transferred their
ownership to the W after the help of
Allah subhanahu wa taala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more update now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dears
so I came across a video of khabib being
kicked off an airplane we're going to
watch the video but fig out all of the
scenario what happened there was
something that was in that video I don't
know if a lot of you guys clocked on but
you know I did um let's watch for
ourself in what is the reason why he got
kicked out and let's see what lessons we
can
learn I know
language know how to and
now okay so what we're going to do is
we're either going to what you see cuz
my flight attendants are not allowing
you to sit in the exit room or you're
going to have to get off this plane and
we because they're not
comfortable
my
unun yes it
is and they said yes I understand that
but it's also off of their judgement I'm
not going to do this back and forth I
will call a supervisor you can either
take a different seat or we can go ahead
and off the
pl which one are we
doing okay I'll call supervisor and then
we're going to have to re you for
aosh do
[Music]
guys you saw that for yourself Allah now
it's very interesting now one thing that
caught my attention was obviously the
the bigotry of the airlines this is not
in America you know you know um they
accusing him of not to knowing the
language first then they say no it's not
the language if there's anyone that can
open that door in an emergency it is
khabib if you can't open the man
wrestles with a bear yeah if he cannot
open it nobody can so this what happens
when you race your profile something
imagine something happen on that plane
if there's anybody that is sitting in
the best place in that exit is khabib
nobody else but because of the bigotry
and RAC racism they're taking him out
now a few things I noticed number one
he's sitting he's not in business class
he's sitting just with everyone else
which is very interesting yeah because
at the end of the day he can be riding
business class for that matter he could
be going on a private jet he has the
money you can see what kind of a man he
is this just further proves what kind of
a character what kind of individual is
what kind of a man his father brought
him up to be Subhan Allah it talks a lot
about his religion Islam yes which
people don't want to associate anything
good about a Muslim oh no it's going to
do with religion why you have to bring
his religion to it anything bad it's
definitely Islam that's one thing that
um I noticed um now secondly is that if
you notice that he gets up and he just
goes he could easily come and say I'm
khabib do you know who I am Etc he just
tries to reason with the lady tries to
reason more talks more doesn't and just
gets up and gos if it was somebody else
they if if Conor McGregor was there
he'll be like what the f are you doing
do you know who I am I have was it 12
proper 12 Al Whatever it is like a
crackhead yeah okay he would be arrogant
he would never he would never number one
fly on a plane like that okay um uh in
that aspect you oh I got private jet or
this that you know but you can see how
humble he is that he's traveling and he
just reasoned with her if look I mean if
I was that situation I was I'm not
getting up for nothing you going kick me
out for what yeah but you can see that
Subhan Allah how humble and reasonable
he is but he just complies and you know
even though they are wrong even though
they are wrong yes for what reason are
you taking him out so guys I need you
guys inah we need to help our brother
khab and boycott message Alaskan
Airlines whatever that matter and put
that pressure we want to know why he was
kicked off that plane for no damn reason
because some flight attended on someone
said oh I think he should not be there
for what reason for what reason tell us
the reason why he's young it's not like
he's an olderly person old person no yes
we know they have the duty of finding
the correct person to sit there yes they
can't have somebody who is not able to
who his olderly elderly Etc whatever for
that matter there could be many factors
for that matter but there's no reason
for someone as young as khabib to be
taken out so it can be and I'm assuming
either islamophobia or some kind of
racial reasons where they they done this
before yeah not maybe Alaskan Airlines
it's happened before so brother s
inshallah tag alkan Airlines on X or
whatever it is for that matter inshallah
and report them brothers and sisters we
want answers Okay this not going to
carry on as Muslims we are made to feel
like we are some kind of like you know
and we are the ones that's been
massacred around the world and they call
us terrorists we can you imagine that
they are the ones that commit the
greatest terrorism worldwide glob
the US Army globally and then we Muslims
are the ones that the troublemakers it's
clear alhamdulillah it is clear who the
troublemakers are and alhamdulillah with
his character and his behavior as a
Muslim this is how we should behave yes
this is how it should be that's why the
prophet said like and even the Quran it
says repel evil with that which is good
and the one that you have enity with
there will be friendship yes and the
prophet Muhammad PE upon him said I have
come to nothing for nothing but to
perfect good character yes and that
speaks volumes of khabib's attitudes and
how he reacted to these
sadly people may Allah bless and protect
him in brother sister that's all I
wanted to say may Allah bless and guide
you guys inah look after yourself